good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday yes
that's right it is only tuesday
only tuesday thank god the morning toast
is here to brighten up your tuesday
morning and deliver the past five and
talk about everything fabulous
and thco is here to make that brightness
even brighter
even brighter if you thought we couldn't
get any brighter then thea walked up and
was like what's up [ __ ] like
bam we'd have a funny story to tell you
um is it about you kind of
okay so i told you i saw my friends
literally for the first time
since quarantine was over um and we went
to dinner last night and we just had
like so much can you go anywhere good
i'm actually went to a fabulous kosher
restaurant because you know they say
between rosh hashanah and yom kippur you
should eat kosher as much as possible
and it's 18 on 81st between second and
third fabulous fabulous food
and we were just like there was so much
to catch up on like
and someone you know very graciously
asked how theo was
and i guess i just didn't realize like
we talk about him like he's human and
it's so normal
and i've really not seen anyone except
for you like since quarantine started
and i was talking about you know all
these new energies with michaela and
margo's new puppy magnolia
and how it's we thought it might affect
his spirit but it turns out he's just
like such a star
and i was just really really like
leaning into talking him about him like
he was a full-blown human
right and i guess like my friends just
like weren't used to it and they
like literally looked at me like i had
eight heads they're like what are you
talking about
and they were like oh it's like funny
i'm like no i'm being dead serious like
thea was
doing better than ever and like his
mental health is in check and like
they like thought i was joking and like
they just did not get like at all like
the vibe that theo is a human you know
yeah well you know what i'll say to that
i feel like when you see your friends
like you're always going to fancy
restaurants or doing this or that
and they don't actually spend quality
time with theo that's true so they don't
know like the level of emotional
intelligence that he's capable of they
haven't seen his highs they haven't seen
his lows
they haven't seen him in the mountain
air just like with a spring in his step
right and then they haven't seen him
back in the city with the mountain blues
yeah we actually
we can't fault them or blame them
because it's just not their fault they
haven't been privy to firsthand
to the wondrous experience that is theo
it's so true
so it's not their fault and i think it
just
underscores that they need to spend more
time with theo and i think everybody
needs to spend more time with you yeah
and then also right before i went to
dinner just piggybacking off of our zara
chat yesterday
i already told you this but i think the
podcasters will enjoy this really
awkward experience i had it sarah
um so like we said yesterday you could
return zara at any store which is like
the best store policy
so i went right before dinner just to
return some of the items that we bought
um and there was actually this jacket
that i had i'm so proud of you for
returning
so like if it if i don't return within
the first 24 hours of knowing
it's going to be an old bag in the
corner for five years and one day i will
wear it just to make it worse
than never returning yeah so um i went
to the zara and there was actually this
jacket that i really liked but just
didn't fit me it was like meant to be
cropped and that just doesn't work for
me
so i thought maybe if i sized up it
would like fit normally
so i went searching around the store to
look for an xl on the jacket and they
did not have it so whatever i was like
giving up
went to the register returned all the
items and the guy was like did you want
any of these in another size like i
could order it and ship it to your house
i'm like oh my god fabulous
i guess i need that pink jacket and an
xl
and then it was like kind of quiet you
know when i say excel i'm like excel
like i'm not screaming it i'm not like
if i was a small i would be like i'll
have a small
but no i'm like i'll have an xl and
so a few seconds go by it's like doing a
little dilly dally on his phone he was
like and he said it's so loud by the way
he's like
you wanted a double xl right and i'm
like
no could you quiet down please um i
wanted an xl
and then it was just like really awkward
because it was just like
i don't know if it would have been
awkward if it was like did you want to
double x extra small
but it was just weird and then he made
it even weirder by like acknowledging it
he was like
oh i'm sorry i didn't mean to like
assume your size and i'm like oh no it's
like
it's totally fine and i literally never
wanted to die more and there were like
so many people in line i was just like i
know they're all overhearing this
incredibly
painful painful uh social interaction
and that's my story and that's why i
just shop online yeah that's really
rough
um it's like nice that he apologized but
i think him acknowledging it
like it wasn't he didn't do anything
wrong i know but you know like he's
going home like telling his friends
and going on his podcast saying like oh
my god i'm so embarrassing like
i slipped up and it's just pit inducing
all around
you know it was really like really one
of the most awkward interactions of my
life
and i'm like not awkward like yeah
you're not i'm like a beast like i could
make a situation funny like
there was just no salvaging this
interaction it was really painful did
you get the jacket though
yes it's being shipped to my house very
exciting that is very exciting was it
that pink one that i
pulled up yeah did you get the pants the
pants fit fine oh you got them but the
jacket is like cropped
with like an electric not electric
elastic waistband that like hugs your
belly
you know what i got a sweatshirt a
last-minute addition to my pile
and it has that elastic waistband that
hugs her belly and i do wish i sized up
in it
i don't think i'm gonna go take it back
i'll just wear it and you guys will see
one day
very exciting very exciting um did you
go and get that sweater with the pockets
that you want that you eyed on your way
out
no the store that i went to was like a
much smaller version we went to the one
on 52nd and madison uh
and fifth and if you live in the city it
is like the best sarah ever i think it's
considered like the new york
flagship store it's so big it's like
triple the size of every store in the
city
i think that's just sarah no no because
there's also one on lex that's super big
not fifth across from bloomingdale
everyone knows like the 52nd and fifth
one is the best one
and the one never hurt i went to the one
across from bloomingdale's because it
was
my dinner and it was tiny in comparison
it's still two floors
but they didn't have half the inventory
interesting new york steens 52nd and
fitzera is the best one
head on over there i'm wearing zara
today my shirt this one's like has a
little issue because
the buttons like there's an app in
between the buttons but we're all close
here
you say zara or zara like this is like
the i know yesterday you were saying it
one way and i was saying it the other
way i can't it's like data or data i
don't know what i say until i say it
yeah and sometimes i say data and
sometimes i say data yeah it just
depends on how i'm feeling
yeah i'm updating updated to ios 14
that's like kind of been like the big
change in my life this week
and honestly i usually really really do
not like updating my phone but i would
say it's
a welcome change it's just refreshing
it's very similar lots of
new things pretty much everything's the
same can't recommend enough
i need to get a genius power appointment
because my screen is still cracked from
the day i filmed the day in the live
vlog for patreon
oh my god i need a new screen but like
i've been having a hard time getting the
appointments like that's my current
cross to bear yeah the apple store is
just like not a place
that i want to be and i want to invest
in you know i don't want to invest my
time and my energy
but i have to work that i have to go at
a certain point you just have to go or i
have to get a new phone but i just got a
new phone so yeah
i'm not going to do that um speaking of
patreon head over to patreon.com slash
your morning toast if you're looking for
more content from us
um we have three episodes up this month
you get five extra episodes a month the
episodes are either
vlogs or podcasts depends every month um
and you pay 7.99 for those five episodes
and then access to our
exclusive members only facebook group
which is the toast after dark which is a
safe place on the internet
which is very rare these days very very
rare very special much like thco who's
just like nuzzling in my lap like this
is kind of the best iteration of thco
i've been
actually watching all of our episodes
when i get home every day because oh
what do you think is it a good show
i feel like for a while i never watched
our own show but i think that in order
to
like always be better and more on top of
your game like you got to watch your
game tape you got to watch your game
tape even though it's my least favorite
thing
um sometimes it's so funny and i'm
always like looking at myself in the
camera like claudia fix your hair so
like maybe that's what uh let me fix my
hair like just in case
future me is wanting me to fix my hair
okay um
you've been watching the show and i
realized like theo pretty much
exclusively sits on your lap even though
he's my dog and i like lug him here
every day just for you to reap the
benefits
and i just think changes need to be made
we're gonna have to have a meeting after
this with me even theo
i understand i think what he's trying to
say though is like he knows that
he spends 23 hours of the day with you
and like and he loves him and misses him
so much and he's just throwing me a
freaking bone here
yeah you know well you know what theo
really loves you
so much it's really it warms my heart
that like
he doesn't just like love his parents
like he loves he loves he has so much
love in his heart he loves his grandma
ben's mom he
adores like literally you have to pry
him away from her house i think it's
because she gives some extra treats but
whatever
i don't i don't do like cheap toys like
that no but she
a theo he loves you so much and so you
know what i have no choice but to accept
it
oh my god and i love and you know i love
him so much i know i know and it's like
how could i get in the way of that i
would literally throw myself in front of
a bus 100
i would run into traffic if it meant to
like save his life and and
mine i would take a bullet for him
hundred percent a thousand percent
thousand percent love you th
love you so much um last night i
finished the book for the redheads
the unraveling of cassidy holmes it was
so good it's like so pop culture centric
is kind of like dark and depressing but
the imagery that's like they've seen the
picture that's painted it's like so
early 2000s like girl band
okay you know vmas music videos etc and
it was a really good book so i'm really
excited to talk about it with the
redheads and you know it's never too
late to become a redhead ever
new episode drops next thursday that is
so much time for you to read a good book
um so check it out and then check out
all of our other tnn shows lauren
elizabeth has constantly dropping new
episodes margaret josephs
raven gates and alexis and the snatcher
comes back in october
wow i'm excited for the snatcher to
re-snatch
yeah re-snatch your hearts she's
snatching hearts all over the nation
that also means that the doctor comes
back which i'm also excited for because
as i've been watching love island and
they really created like
a bubble there where i'm watching it and
it no longer they're filming it like
yesterday but it doesn't feel like it's
in a pandemic and it's really nice to
watch
it's making me excited for the bachelor
because they're in a bubble
yeah and because it's like real shows
getting back to what they do yeah you
know
yeah i'm like really not looking forward
to the claire
part of the season but very much looking
forward to the tasha part of the season
yeah i think it'll be interesting
yeah so it'll be something to talk about
that's not housewives yes we're gonna
ease up on the housewives talk as
promised
um and deliver the past five do you say
it's time to dive right in i think it's
time to get right into the fast side
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and jackie i know that you
have this platform and you have your job
to do
but i don't get emotional but um
i have something to say and if i if i
may just grab the floor really quick use
your voice
today's episode is brought to you by new
x at new x
our mission is to provide our customers
with the highest quality products
at a reasonable price with years of
experience in sourcing manufacturing and
development
their goal is to make cbd accessible to
the masses we never sacrifice quality
and all of their products are
natural pure and tested so i've actually
been in the cbd game for like two years
and i've been taking the new x gummies
like i don't know maybe two months and i
feel as though
they're my favorite products so far
they're very effective i take cbd um
a few hours before bed i find that like
my anxiety's at an all-time high before
bed because you're just like left
with your thoughts like laying around so
i take it a few hours before bed and i
feel like i'm so calm before bed i like
watch my shows so peacefully
and then having trouble falling asleep
is like one of the worst things ever
so the cbd gummies really just like
check all the boxes for me um they taste
really really good
um they have 15 milligrams of broad
spectrum cbd per gummy they're vegan and
they're made with all natural
ingredients
they have no artificial colors flavors
or sweeteners they are thc
free they are grown in the usa with usa
grown hemp
they are lab tested and they're under 10
so it's really fabulous for anyone who's
looking for a fun and unique way to take
cbd um
they're really sweet and actually very
very delicious very tasty they're 9.99
um for the pack of gummies and they're a
consistent dose every time so like when
i've been on my cbd journey it's like
some of the
products like are just not very well
made and it's like there's a whole can
of gummies and like they all have
different doses
so you don't know like what you're
taking which is really really
frustrating but new x
each gummy is perfectly dosed the exact
same amount which is i feel like really
really important so you know what you're
putting in your body
agreed visit newex.com to go purchase
some of their great products you can use
the discount code toast
for twenty percent off but just for a
limited time the website is nu dash
x dot com and the promo code is toast
for 20
off for a limited time um it's a
fabulous product fabulous brand can't
recommend it enough i've been taking cbd
for a while and
these stand the test of time they really
do they really do i was enjoying them
last week like
take one a few hours before bed read for
me oh that's nice and it's just like
that's how you find your inner peace in
the city and that's how you wind down
like yes you can't just like go from
like a mile a minute bed computer
everything tv and then just like expect
to fall asleep like you really need to
invest in winding down i think it's like
a huge
wellness thing i'm just very into
wellness now yeah you are you're
really the face of wellness what'd you
say you're the face of inner peace
well that's true yeah okay first story
is such exciting news vanderpump rule
stars jax taylor and brittany cartwright
are expecting their first child there's
another vanderpump rules baby on the way
jax taylor and brittany cartwright are
expecting their first child the couple
who wed in kentucky in june 2019
announced the baby news on monday on
instagram
holding up several sonograms in the
photos she shared on her social media
smiles while she and jax hold her baby
bump together
quote mom and dad the love of our lives
is coming soon she
captioned the post she um said
to people magazine quote we've been
trying for around five months and we
just can't wait to grow our family
i had the ovulation sticks and all the
apps we were ready to go
said the mom to be who was currently 11
weeks into her pregnancy
i woke up super early to go to the
restroom and just had a feeling i should
take a test and it was positive
i cried i laughed we were just so happy
then i took three more tests and cried
some more
by the way i cannot believe how much has
changed within the vanderpump rules
universe like
in the last six months like in
quarantine like a couple people got
fired
three people are now pregnant it's just
like a completely different show and
like quarantine affected it so much you
know it really like most of these people
got pregnant and quarantined
yeah i'm so happy for jackson brittany
like i feel
like they've been talking about starting
a family for a long time i think for a
while people thought that britney
was going to be the first of the group
to have kids because at one point it
felt like they were just going to be
kids forever
right um so i'm really so happy for them
yeah i actually texted brittany and i
was like mazeltov and she was like so
happy she said she's like wanted to be a
mom forever like more than she even ever
wanted like to be married like she
always wanted to be a mom
and that's just like what else could you
ask for i feel like we could feel that
on the show
yeah and you know jax has had like a
very tumultuous time at the you know
passing of his dad and i feel like
this is one of those things that like
really brings you full circle in grief
and i'm sure they'll do something to
like name the baby after jax's dad
and i don't know i feel like this is
just a great path for them to be on like
they really are
grown up i know they're like 40 so it
feels weird but like they're like kids
because they've been on the show for so
long it's hard to like break
out of like the box that you became
famous in especially when you became
famous for being like a
wild wild adult you know it's it's hard
to
enter the next stage of your life but
i'm really happy that a lot of them are
doing that and that they'll all be
pregnant together and then have babies
and it's just a whole new generation
and i'm just this this news warms my
heart
yeah and it's just it's like ideal to be
pregnant like when literally all your
best friends
are pregnant like yeah for the first
time i get i'm sure it makes it like
much less intimidating and like scary
and it's just like a nice thing like you
and your best friends who have all grown
up together like now your kids will grow
up together
it's so crazy and they all live in like
the same neighborhood
it's actually so crazy yeah no it's even
though i don't know if all of them will
stay in la forever but just
it's crazy i feel like if vanderpump
rules like ever does come to an end i
feel like jackson brady will probably be
the first ones to leave like
first of all britney is just like so
connected to kentucky and like the south
and i feel like we've heard jax complain
about l.a like a million times on the
show and he's not from there
yeah but you never know like now that
they're putting down roots and they have
a house and they have friends and the
friends that are gonna have kids like
plans change plans change really really
beautiful congratulations
i don't know why like this story shocked
me even though like they're married and
like
everyone's pretty much like been waiting
for this when i saw it i was like oh my
god i was surprised
i was surprised too when i was really
happy i i know what you mean it was kind
of surprising even though like it's the
next logical step for them
it's just good happy news yeah i guess
because there have been already two
vanderpump rules pregnancy announcements
and if you would have asked me who would
have would have been
i would have said jackson brittany about
both of them like i really would have
never suspected
stasi or um so now i guess it's just
like i forgot you know
yeah no it's it's very exciting news
okay next up emmy 2020 ratings the
awards viewership
sink to an all-time low that is the
least shocking
thing ever because after our discussion
yesterday i went on youtube and watched
like a bunch of people's acceptance
speeches
and unfortunately i was forced to watch
like the little gimmicks they did
on stage with jimmy kimmel um and there
were a few things i did like i think
when dan levy won
um they did like a ups partnership like
thinking essential workers and they had
like a real ups driver give the um
announce who won which i thought was
very very sweet but like with like this
jennifer aniston and like jason sedakis
like garbage
that they were putting the skits they
were putting on stage like with the fire
extinguisher
and the lysol like it was so incredibly
stupid
and i hope that they have bad ratings so
they know to never
[ __ ] like do that again yeah and i know
that you had to get creative because of
quarantine and i respect that but there
are other award shows who are not
nearly as shitty i i completely agree
there's no excuse
none an average audience of 5.1 million
viewers watched the socially distant
ceremony
down from last year's already record low
of 6.9 million
it's a lot of people but like these
award shows are supposed to be like
big football games are like you know
they're supposed to be like 10
million they should be 20 million
everyone watches these shows the
celebrities like think that
everyone cares about them but not
everyone's watching the
award shows i guess it just feels like a
lot because my frame of reference for
like ratings
is housewives i mean i follow like a
bunch of housewives accounts that like
always are
circulating the housewives numbers and
for the most part each franchise reaches
about 2 million viewers every week
and that feels like a lot um and then so
it's like to me everyone in the world
watches
housewives so it's like if the emmy's
got 5 million wow that's double you know
yeah no i don't think of it that way at
all not everyone watches housewives to
me and also
housewives aren't on basic cable that's
true so
it's just yeah i guess five million is
really low it should
be similar to like football when you
think about the amount of viewers who
watch these top shows like
when there's game of thrones on and like
how many million
so if those people care about these
actors like what did they tune in to see
if their favorites won
right like these shows are nominated
because they're so big and they have
millions and millions of followers
so wouldn't that translate to the emmys
that's a really good point i guess but
that's how much people hate the emmys
and and we are those people
so i can understand i mean not only i
feel uh are the
you know the integrity of the emmys on
the decline but given the current
you know situation and there wasn't
really like a quote unquote real award
show
um it was just less and less people who
needed to watch it by the way what you
said yesterday about
um how they must have known who was
gonna win if they brought the trophy to
them i guess like the hazmat suit people
went to everyone's house and when
they didn't win they walked away with a
trophy so like everyone had a trophy
waiting for them at that at their house
oh that is so awkward so like you
literally put it in there like
it could almost get it in their orbit
and then they didn't get it
interesting okay i like that like to me
the best part of award shows is truly
the element of surprise
which is why like i find regular not
this year but most
like vmas to be so weren't because
i feel like the artist knows and like
it's so coordinated it's like a pr thing
um i love like the legit awards because
i love seeing celebrities kind of in
that vulnerable position like really
wanting to win and like having to clap
when they don't and then being genuinely
surprised
that's like one of the best parts of
award shows yeah um
also next story very funny zendaya fans
mistake the meaning of upset
after historic emmys 2020 win oh my god
okay so i followed this saga on twitter
because
at first new york post or page six
released an article
yes new york post released an article
the tweet was biggest upset zendaya wins
emmy's 2020 over jennifer aniston laura
linney
and then her fans who didn't understand
the meaning of
upset in this context context were like
i wasn't upset zendaya's performance in
euphoria was phenomenal
oh my god okay so i literally and
someone else
no one's upset someone else won't hate
to see a powerful woman
winning in a word she deserves i see oh
my god literally so i was following the
saga because the tweet was up and i
follow page six and new york post
and there were so many replies and i'm
like this is an insane number of replies
for like a regular article
and all these kid like stan accounts
were freaking out like
really trying to take down page six like
thinking that they were coming for
zendaya and i was laughing so hard and
then i
love that paychecks like turned around
and made it a story because it's so
funny it's so so funny this is like
where
like stan twitter is like so toxic
sometimes like this is where it's so
funny because at the end of the day it's
like just a bunch of kids
no but also it's like we reported
yesterday like zendaya is the youngest
person to win
this award and like that's what you get
when a young person wins this award
for the first time their young fans
don't understand the miscommunication
the language like about them this is
just like one of those internet things
that i live for
yeah it was a really funny story still
really happy for zendaya
yeah fabulous fabulous but it wasn't
upset like going against
some of the biggest names in the
industry who have been acting for like a
million
and who have been nominated multiple
times and she wanted i think she took i
didn't watch
i didn't finish euphoria but like that
was a show that just like totally took
over
the conversation you know what i mean it
was a cultural reset
and a show like that deserves to win i
feel that like
that way about it's creek too yes you
know i don't think the morning show
really
did anything of the sort no when the
morning show like first
hit the scene it was like such a big
deal just because it was jennifer
aniston and reese witherspoon and like a
dynamic duo on the same show
and i guess they like alluded to a lot
of like real life things that had
happened like within the metoo movement
but i feel like the rise and fall of the
morning show was real [ __ ] quick
yeah i never even saw a lick of it and
i'm proud of that i never finished the
first season
it's okay okay next story some exciting
interesting news i thought
mario didiot daddy of novik
debuts cosmetics brand makeup by mario
and his first launch is all about eyes
so makeup by mario kim's makeup artist
is launching a
cosmetics brand called makeup by mario
in partnership with sephora
and i just think this is so on point
yeah i mean i'm honestly shocked that
it kind of took him so long to get his
own makeup line because he's kind of
been
the the end-all be-all of like the
makeup industry and just
makeup like celebrity makeup artist and
like kim and him like
really created this like whole celebrity
celebrity makeup artist like
relationship and people respect him so
much and he's done a bunch of collabs
and he did like a sephora brush collab
but i'm just like surprised that it took
until 2020 for him to have his own line
because
for the last i would say like five years
he's been at the head of the makeup
industry
yeah i think for a while he was
consulting with kim on kkw
and i think like he's been working
really hard and
this is like just a really exciting the
culmination
the culmination of all of that but i
think he's like between his work like he
started out working at sephora
then he's like the biggest celebrity
makeup artist in the world then he's
kind of consulting for a huge celebrity
makeup brand so like this is the next
logical step and i feel like he has all
of the experience for this to be like
a major major brand and i love the name
because it's so perfect it's so perfect
and the packaging is so cute it's like a
black and white
like monochromatic theme um and i will
definitely be purchasing
i just you'd love to see it like people
who just work really hard and get
successful you know
yeah i i do really love to see it and
it'll be successful because like kim
is just like obviously going to support
it because they both have done so much
for each other
and you love to see like friends
supporting friends yeah
you really do i don't know i just
thought it was a really great story i
feel like everyone really comes out with
a
makeup brand these days some hits some
don't but i just feel like this is one
that's a no-brainer
yeah um i feel like mario's actually
someone who i wouldn't mind
seeing like a youtube documentary on i
feel like he like leads a very busy life
yeah very busy i don't understand how
certain makeup artists like at the
height of you know when we were doing
things
like how they have enough time in the
day for all of the people that they work
with
well so i feel like when you get to that
level there's such a high bar like i
remember one of
someone i knew had reached out to like a
mary phillips or like one of them
one of the kardashian makeup people to
do them for their wedding um just like
to see what the price would be and not
only was like the fee
absolutely insane i think like twenty
thousand dollars for the day what you
have to pay in like agency fees because
they all have agents now and then the
travel for them and an assistant and
five-star hotel for like it's insane
like celebrity makeup artists have they
themselves become celebrities and the
cost of doing business with them is like
i don't think you get someone to do your
makeup for without an all-in cost of
like fifty thousand dollars
yeah and that eliminates the amount of
people who you can realistically do i
don't think mario is doing like people's
wedding makeup but like
he does so many celebrities yeah any
like how does he do he does gabrielle
union
yeah i don't know i also think about
like chris appleton like
yeah are we doing like kim and j lo like
don't they each of them just
both of them i don't know how you could
do both of them but like my dream is i
mean i guess like he was here and like
he did touch our hair but like i should
have taken advantage of that because
ever since like meeting him and then
like really starting to follow his work
like
he is literally one of the most talented
people i would die for him to do my hair
okay if you could have
a celebrity makeup artist and hair
stylist like do your fatch for like the
biggest event
who would you have i would definitely do
chris appleton for my hair
and i would either do makeup by ariel or
make up my mario to do my face like
kardashian glam
galore what about you i would do makeup
by arielle for my face
and i would do justine marshawn for my
hair oh that's a good one or
patrick taw for my face he's like really
really talented and he did addison ray's
and she looked amazing always doing that
eyebrow thing he does
madeleine's eyebrows and they look so
good and that's what i need in my life
it's just so funny how like this
industry
like created like celebrities from it
mm-hmm it's that better i do think
so much of that is on the kardashians
right
like glam like the process of glam
you know an activity in itself like
yeah like the glam rooms in their house
yeah and the support and the filming of
glam and
it's just like it's not just something
you do in the dark and then you show up
and you're glam like it's like a whole
process yeah and it's not like i feel
like for a while celebrities used to
show up at red carpets like would spend
eight hours to get ready and just like
show up looking effortless and wanting
people to think like they just like
really truly woke up like this
whereas the kardashians were the first
people to open up be like no it actually
takes me a full day to look normal
yeah yeah and i also think that plus the
advent of instagram where it's like all
the tagging and the looks and instagram
makeup like it's just this whole
ecosystem now and it's one that i i
truly enjoy and it's one that a lot of
people are cashing in on like
so many celebrity makeup artists i
haven't tried anything from rare beauty
but i actually have been
watching so many tutorials enough
because she's been really hitting the
circuit
yeah and i've been watching so many
reviews and i didn't want to watch only
people who
she collabed with because of course
they're going to say only nice things
like i wanted to get some real reviews
from people like with tons of different
skin tones and different like needs for
products
and honestly for the most part people
really like it it looks really nice
the commercials are great and yes i've
been seeing commercials on my tv
which is like crazy next time i casually
go into sephora like maybe i'll pick up
a lipstick
yeah i feel like though like at the end
of the day like in terms of celebrity
makeup like fenty's always going to
reign supreme
and like they were the first to do it
with like the most inclusive foundation
line
and everything they release is just like
so bomb that
yeah yeah that's it that is it fifth and
final story little cosmetic news liam
mcsweeney reveals she got a nose job
oh wow liam mcsweeney is owning up to
her plastic surgery the rhony star took
to her instagram story on sunday night
to reveal she had a nose job
and show off her bruises that's so
interesting i would never i never even
noticed her nose i actually noticed her
nose only because
she has the exact same nose as her mom
and her sister oh and when you're like
watching them together i don't even know
why i'm not someone who notices noses at
all
you get a nose job and i wouldn't know
but i was just trying to find the
resemblance between all three of them
because people always were saying that
her and her sister looked alike
and then when i saw it it was in the
nose got it but i thought that she had a
nice nose but i guess it bothered her so
she said people are damning me like
crazy inquiring why i have black eyes
and asking if i got a nose job asking if
i got beat up i'm not trying to hide
anything from anybody i got a
rhinoplasty and a septoplasty
i could not be happier she said people
who are transparent about plastic
surgery
i've been wanting one for so freaking
long and now i can also breathe which is
great
yeah i love people who are transparent
about plastic surgery
and i'm excited to see like the genesis
of her nose on the next season
yeah well so i actually was talking to
you about this off camera yesterday but
i wanted to say it on the show because
we had a really long discussion last
week about
liam mcsweeney um not being able to
negotiate yet her salary with bravo
because she wanted like some
kind of outrageous price jump for a
first-time housewife even though she is
a fan favorite
and the more i thought about it i
changed my mind on it because if we
really want
liam mcsweeney like i loved everything
about liam mcsweeney except for the fact
that like she doesn't really live like
the typical life
of what you consider to be a real
housewife which is like big fancy
apartment
and so you know what if she doesn't have
that like bravo needs to give it to her
so that she can have that one thing that
she's missing
yeah okay whatever it takes for you to
come around yeah but
i've heard that she has like not started
filming yet because they still haven't
negotiated
no well sorry there's an article on page
six this morning and i saw on instagram
that she responded to a comment saying
like she's coming back there's no
and i don't think i ever questioned
whether or not she would come back she
was never gonna like walk away after one
season
but she is going to get as much as she
can
good for her yeah she said she replied
to an instagram comment saying i'm
coming back
my work here isn't done yet no it's
definitely no it's definitely not so
i'm i'm i'm happy with that development
i think that
that they're going to start filming like
dana we always say that about new york
like even last year we'd be like
it's like they're going to start filming
next week well they film at the end of
summer i know but
i just feel like it's always the end of
summer yeah i just feel like you know
and also like with everything getting
pushed back they really
should start filming like at the
holidays if we're honoring the pushback
yeah yeah yeah yeah but i don't think
that's i think they're gonna start
filming soon um
and then following up on a story i know
we said we wouldn't talk that much about
housewives but just one other thing
we were talking about that teddy
mellencamp story we reported daily mail
says that like she's gonna be fired this
week
and when we wrapped yesterday page six
was also reporting that but now a whole
day has gone by and there's been no news
interesting i just took it as fact after
page six reported it that she
no i know but like it's not backed
because like
the housewife always announces when she
leaves you know interesting
i guess maybe she'll wait till oh no
reunion ended
i don't know someone to think about
something to think about
um anything else we want to discuss
there was no tv on last night
and no i watched love island now i'm
like officially caught up so i can watch
the episodes
live um and it definitely feels like the
last day of camp now that like i don't
know ever since mackenzie left i just
feel like i'm waiting for
the show to end and how long does it go
on i don't know i just feel like it's
going on forever and i feel like
the couples that are together like are
gonna stay together and then everyone
else just sort of like you know is
always
head turned like their heads are being
turned and there's just no like at a
certain point
the show kind of gets over and i feel
like that's where we're
at um but so i was telling about conor
and mackenzie and he got eliminated
last night and then he facetimed her and
like he's going to go to arizona
do they have their phones in the so yeah
they have phones in the villa
because they get text messages from
producers that like tell them what
they're going to be doing next
but and they are able to take pictures
that they like can use on social media
and stuff
but i don't think they have like text
messaging and and like can make phone
calls from it it's just like a prop for
right for communication with like within
the island yes interesting and they're
always walking around with the phones
which just confuses me like
couldn't like they're they're carrying
them at the most inopportune times like
camp if producers want to reach them
can't they see like who has the phone on
them and then right
text that person instead of everyone
having to carry that yeah these types of
shows like interest me in terms of the
logistics like how do you logistically
keep all these people
like on an island well not this time but
is it usually filmed on
an actual island yes like in fiji like
in fiji oh fabulous
yeah and also the logistics of the show
were really interesting and then after
season one you weren't here to stay
but we had alex from season one who was
the runner-up of last season
and i literally sp like 20 questions
just about the logistics of the show so
if you want to know how the show works
i would go back and watch that episode
because she answers like all of these
questions about like the texting do they
always have to scream i gotta text why
do they scream it like right
just all of these really interesting
things that i found to be interesting
okay fabulous um i didn't want you
anything yesterday like i had the
busiest day of my life like work work
work being a blogger so many emails so
little time
um so i didn't get a chance to watch
anything dancing with the stars was not
on last night it's on tonight
but i'm not sure if i want to commit to
the season it is such a big commitment
like
it's really like committing to the
bachelor like it's two hours a week
sometimes they do twice a week
and to be honest i'm just like in this
nice period where like real housewives
of new york is over
real housewives of beverly hills is over
like i'm enjoying my evenings
and now that like indoor dining is about
to return to new york and outdoor dining
is like in full effect i think i need to
start like freeing up my life and saying
yes to life and no to tv i know
i think like we need to start hitting
the town
no i know yeah and i think like it
really hinders my nights out when i know
i have to come home and watch two hours
of dancing with the stars
oh yeah so i think i'm sure you need to
take the nights off that you can get
like because wednesday and thursday or
whatever night is always going to be
rony now and now with kardashian so
thursday night
sunday night potomac yeah so like if you
can get a monday off before the bachelor
comes back i would do it
i tuesday off i would do it i think my
journey to inner peace doesn't include
me watching dancing with the stars but
it just included me like watching the
performances on youtube later you know
yeah i can commit to that i like i like
that for you
yeah it's just if i've learned to
anything from this you know trying an
unprecedented time
it's to take time for yourself and it's
okay to be selfish it is okay to be
i think ben doesn't really agree but i
do
no i think that that it is it's
definitely and you know who agrees with
t.h.e.o
well he's been really focusing on kind
of his self-care routine and just
his version of winding down yeah and
he's always wound down like look at him
he's literally lives in a constant state
of wound downness
and that is so wonderful i'm so jealous
of him i love him so much
i think that's all she wrote yeah short
show because there was no tv on and like
no major breaking news but we hope that
you enjoy today's show
um if you're looking for more content
again all of our tnn shows have new
episodes coming out this week
and our patreon which is patreon.com
morning toast is ready for you to become
a member 7.99
um also my comedy specials you know
still you know just popping off popping
off
amazon itunes apple tv all the places so
if you're looking for something else to
do head over watch my comedy special
disgraced queen people are just loving
it and
that's all you can ask for um thank you
guys so much for listening today's
episode
what do i say thank you guys so much for
watching thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast monday
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories that you need to know
on youtube and monday through friday so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we are also
available as a podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so that's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio ir radio cast box
all the places now we're also available
on amazon music so wherever you listen
to podcasts find us
the morning toast oh wait i have
something to say and leave a five star
review about beautiful stunning and
smart we are
also today is a celebratory occasion
because after literally
three years two years the morning toast
instagram has been
verified it has been my personal journey
and passion project
and i finally reaped benefits thank you
to whoever heard my
cries at instagram i see you i hear you
and i appreciate you
and i love you and make sure to follow
us on instagram at the morning toast and
have a great day
bye bye goodbye
you